The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
We have a few more PowerPoint
things before I am going to
attempt using the board.
Again, we are in the transition
metal unit.
And today we are going to
introduce something called
crystal field theory.
And this is in Chapter 16 in
your book.
Let me just tell you about two
different theories.
Again, chemistry is an
experimental science.
We collect data,
and then we try to come up with
theories that explain the data,
so the theories are not sort of
100%.
And some are more simple and
some are more complicated,
to try to explain what we
observe.
And some of these theories,
although they are pretty simple
approximations of what is really
going on, do a pretty good job
of explaining the things that we
are observing.
All right.
There are two different kinds
of theories that you will hear
about with transition metals.
You will hear about crystal
field theory and ligand field
theory.
And so these were,
again, developed to explain
certain types of properties of
coordination complexes of
transition metals.
There is observed data.
And then people tried to think
about how you could rationalize
what was observed.
The basic idea behind these
theories is that if you have
your metal ion with its given
oxidation number,
and it is in the center of a
coordination sphere,
the energy levels of the
d-orbitals for that particular
metal are going to be altered
when ligands are bound compared
to sort of a free system.
The binding of ligands around
that metal, where there are
those d-orbitals associated with
that metal, is going to have an
effect and create special
properties.
Crystal field theory,
which is what we are going to
be talking about,
is based on an ionic
description.
Basically you are going to be
considering your ligands as
negative point charges,
a negative charge.
And you are going to ask the
question, is that negative
charge pointed toward a
d-orbital?
If so, that will be repulsive.
And that is going to have an
effect.
Ligand field theory includes
covalent, as well as ionic
descriptions.
It is a more powerful theory
and it can describe things a
little bit better,
but we don't have enough time
to cover it here.
If you are interested in
transition metals,
you will probably go on and
take another chemistry course
called 5.03, which is inorganic
chemistry.
At this point,
we are just going to be doing
the more simple theory,
which just considers the ionic
descriptions.
But it does pretty well.
You can explain some things
with it, but you should be aware
that you can do a little bit
better with another theory.
You should just be aware of
that, that this is really the
most simplistic kind of
representation or theory to
explain some of the properties
of coordination complexes.
All right.
All of these theories require
you to think in three dimensions
about d-orbitals.
Because they are all about the
interactions with ligands,
either covalent or ionic
interactions,
but they are all about the
interactions of ligands with
those d-orbitals.
I mentioned last time that you
need to know the shapes of the
d-orbitals and you need to be
able to draw them to some
limited ability.
We went through the names of
the d-orbitals last time.
Let's just review it now,
because we are going to be
talking about this more today.
What is this guy up here?
That is d z squared.
And here is our reference
frame.
z is up here,
y along here,
and x is coming out toward you.
What about this one?
d x squared minus y squared.
Down here,
what is that one?
d xy.
The amplitudes are 45
degrees off the axes in the
x,y-plane.
Over here we have d yz,
so now we are along
z.
And the last one is...?
d xz over here.
All right.
Those are the five d-orbitals
that we will be talking about a
lot in the next few lectures.
All right.
Let me just show you.
This is really
three-dimensional,
so let's take a look at the
three-dimensional image of these
d-orbitals.
This is d z squared.
This isn't in your handout,
obviously.
It is a movie,
but you can sort of get a
little better sense of the three
dimensions here.
All right.
The movie first rotates the
axes.
I am not sure why it does that.
And then it is going to rotate
the d-orbitals.
You can see the doughnut in the
middle with the hole and that
the maximum amplitudes are along
the z-axis here.
This is d z squared.
And the orbitals are right
along the z axis,
which is important.
Now let's take a look at d x
squared minus y squared.
The important point here is
that the orbitals are directly
on axis, and the axes are the x
and the y.
You can see how they are
directly along those axes.
All right.
Here is the next one.
Here we have d xy.
And now the orbitals are not
along the axes.
They are 45 degrees in between,
so they are not along,
they are in between,
which is the key point for this
d-orbital in terms of what we
are going to be talking about.
Now we have some amplitude
along the z-axis.
We have z and x.
Again, the orbitals are 45
degrees off the axes.
And we have one more.
Now we have d yz,
again 45 degrees off the axes.
All right.
Now, you should have these sort
of orbitals floating around
inside your head.
And, as we talk about bringing
ligands in toward the orbitals,
you can think about how those
ligands are coming in and what
orbitals they are going to be
near.
Again, crystal field theory is
just considering the ionic
interactions.
And it is really considering
the ligands as negative point
charges.
And so negative point charges
are going to be repulsive with
the d-orbitals.
d-orbitals don't like it when
you have these negatively
charged ligand coming in and
being near.
It will be repulsive near the
d-orbital.
This is just another way to
sort of draw that.
And we have our octahedral
frame.
Here we are talking about a
octahedral geometry.
And we can think about how
ligands are going to be
affecting the d-orbital in these
various places.
If you had ligands on all of
these positions in an octahedral
arrangement around the metal.
And you can think of these
ligands as these negative point
charges.
And so this is just another
depiction.
Here are the d-orbitals again.
It is a slightly different
x,y,z frame, but not too much
different.
And so here are our orbitals.
And these little green dots
represent the point charges.
What we will be thinking about
today is the effect of ligands
being close to the d-orbitals.
You see, here,
there is a ligand that is quite
close up here and one down here.
In this picture,
these negative point charged
ligands are also really close to
the orbitals.
Here they are not really as
close.
They are sort of off-axis.
And that becomes really
important.
All right.
Let's now think about the
different d-orbitals and the
ligands when the ligands are
arranged in an octahedral
geometry.
In this case,
we have these ligands,
these negative point charges
coming in on all the different
axes.
And so, if we think about it,
these are close.
And I mentioned that in the
last slide.
A negative point charge along z
is going to be very close to d z
squared  ,
and it will be repulsive.
For d x squared minus y squared
,
the negative point charges
along y and along x are also
going to be very close to these
d-orbitals.
And that will,
again, be repulsive.
We are going to have a large
repulsive interaction for these
two orbitals with an octahedral
geometry.
These two d-orbitals are
destabilized,
and they are destabilized by
the same amount.
When they are destabilized by
the same amount,
what is that called?
The energy of the orbitals are
the same, what is that called?
Yeah, they are degenerate.
And so these two orbitals,
then, will be more destabilized
by those ligand negative point
charges than the other sets of
orbitals.
Because they are off-axis and
the ligands are on-axis.
The negative point charges will
be farther away from these guys.
Let's take a look at that as
well.
Here we have our three other
d-orbitals.
And if ligands are coming in as
negative point charges on-axis,
they are not going to be
directly pointing at any of
these orbitals.
Because they are 45 degrees
off-axis.
Ligands are on-axis.
It is not directly pointing
toward any of them.
These three orbitals,
then, are stabilized relative
to the other sets of orbitals we
talked about,
and they are stabilized by the
same amount.
Those three are also
degenerate.
All right.
To summarize,
then, you will have a large
repulsion for d x squared minus
y squared   and d
z squared.
And they will be more
destabilized compared to the
other orbitals.
There will be a smaller
repulsion for these three.
And they will be stabilized
compared to these sets of
orbitals.
And so, here,
you are really thinking about
comparing the d-orbitals to a
case where the ligands are sort
of all around.
We will talk about that in a
minute.
If you localize your ligands
on-axis, how is this affected?
And this just reminds you and
shows you the pictures again.
Over here they are pointing
much more directly toward,
and here they are away.
If it helps you,
depending on how you like to
think about it,
I had these orbitals in your
handout on the first page,
but just to show them again.
You can think about how close
they are.
See, that ligand is very close,
not nearly as close here.
It is all about the geometry
around the metal,
the geometry of the d-orbitals,
the geometry of the ligands.
Now I am going to try writing
on the board.
Here we are going to think
about how you would draw a
diagram to represent the energy
levels when you consider crystal
field theory.
You would have what's called a
crystal field splitting diagram.
Here, energy would be going up.
And we have our case.
We have a hypothetical case
where we have five d-orbitals.
And so this is the average
energy of the d-orbitals.
Average energy of d-orbitals
with the ligands bound in what
is known as a spherical crystal
field.
This does not exist.
It is hypothetical.
If the ligands were everywhere
in a sphere around your metal,
this is our hypothetical
spherical crystal field,
and you imagine the metal is
the inside.
And on the outside,
you have all the ligands.
The ligands are everywhere.
They are equally distributed
everywhere.
And if they are equally
distributed everywhere,
all the d-orbitals would have
the same energy.
It is pointing toward
everything equally,
so it is spherical.
It is completely surrounding
the metal.
This is a hypothetical case,
because that does not happen.
Ligands are bound in discrete
positions, but if it did,
these would be of the same
energy.
Let me try to get his a little
more flat.
All right.
They are all the same energy.
Well, what happens,
then, when you bring your
ligands into their discrete
positions, when you bring your
ligands in in this case into
octahedral geometry,
then things change.
Then you have a
destabilization.
You have a destabilization of
your d x squared minus y squared
and d z squared
orbitals.
They are going to go up in
energy.
And you will have a
stabilization of your d xy,
d yz and d xz orbitals.
They are going to go down in
energy.
In this hypothetical case,
the d-orbitals have equal
energy.
Ligands are everywhere.
They are pointing at all the
d-orbitals equally,
but in an octahedral case.
Then two orbitals are
destabilized,
go up in energy,
because those ligands now are
pointing right at those
orbitals.
They are not pointing equally
everywhere.
They are pointing at these
orbitals, so they go up in
energy.
These orbitals are in between
the axes, so they are not
affected as much and get
stabilized.
These orbitals have a name,
e g.
And these orbitals have a name,
t two g for the
octahedral case.
And the difference in energy
between these sets of orbitals
is this sign here,
sort of this delta zero sign,
actually O.
And that is for octahedral.
The O is for octahedral.
And it is the crystal field
splitting energy.
It is how much the ligands
split the field.
This theoretical case up here,
there is no splitting going on.
You bring in d-ligands,
and they cause a splitting.
They cause some orbitals to go
up in energy and some to go
down.
And the distance between them,
the degree of splitting is this
octahedral crystal field
splitting energy.
Now, the overall energy of the
system is maintained.
If these go up and these go
down, to get everything to be
equal, let's see if I drew that
right.
These should go up.
I am trying to draw this
straight from this line.
These are going to go up in
energy by plus two-fifths,
the octahedral crystal
field splitting energy.
And these three orbitals are
going to go down in energy,
will be stabilized,
by minus two-fifths,
the octahedral crystal field
splitting energy.
Two orbitals are going up,
so it is by three-fifths.
Three orbitals are going down,
so it is by two-fifths.
Because it is going to have to
equal out.
You are not sort of creating a
different system here.
The energy is going to be
conserved.
The overall energy is
maintained.
Two orbitals up,
two-thirds.
Three orbitals down,
two-fifths.
Okay.
That is really a simple idea.
Instead of the theoretical
where all the ligands are
everywhere, when you put them in
octahedral geometry it affects
some of the d-orbitals
differently than others.
Some orbitals go up in energy.
Some go down.
The overall energy is
maintained.
Let's look at an example,
now, and figure out how to put
electrons into this system.
Let's look at a case where we
have chromium,
(N H three) three,
and Br three.
First, we need to figure out
the oxidation number of
chromium.
Having everything in the
bracket here means that you have
six ligands total,
three NH three igands,
three Br ligands or bromide
ligands.
And those are all in one
bracket.
There is no number in the
corner of the bracket,
so that means the overall
charge in this system has to be
equal to zero.
What will be the oxidation
number of bromine?
It should be minus one.
Three minus ones.
What about NH three,
as a unit?
Zero.
Three times zero.
And what does that leave you
with for the oxidation number of
chromium?
Plus three.
We have plus three.
Now we can figure out the
d-electron count.
We need to look up the group
number.
And the group number is what?
Can you see it up there?
Most people seem to be saying
six.
That is right.
Six minus three is three.
So this is a d three
system.
That means we are going to put
in three electrons.
Where would you guess I am
going to put those electrons?
Down here or up here?
Down.
What if I do this?
Would that be good?
No.
We are coming back to some of
the roles that you learned
earlier in the semester.
First you want to put them in
the lowest energy orbital.
You don't want to ever have one
with two parallel spins because
that would give you the same
four quantum numbers,
so that is not good.
And you also by choice,
if they are the same energy,
put them in singly before you
start to pair.
Those are all things that you
talked about earlier in the
semester.
We put our three electrons in.
One to each orbital,
all the spins parallel.
We have Aufbau principle,
Pauli exclusion,
and also Hund's rule all at
play here with how we put in the
electrons.
Now we can talk about the d n
electron configuration.
Maybe I can write over here.
That is just a way of
expressing how many electrons
are down here.
d n electron
configuration.
That would just be equal to t
two g to the three.
You list the name of these sets
of orbitals.
And that is really why these
have labels, because it makes
your life easier,
instead of listing all the
orbitals each time.
There are three in this lower
energy level.
Now we can also talk about
crystal field stabilization
energy.
Crystal field stabilization
Don't get this confused with
crystal field splitting energy.
This is crystal field
stabilization energy,
and it is abbreviated CFSE.
And that is really just
thinking about how much you
stabilize by this splitting.
If you had this hypothetical
spherical crystal field,
your electrons would be in
orbitals with this energy,
but they are not.
After the ligands come in,
in the octahedral geometry,
the electrons are in the t two
g orbitals.
They are stabilized.
This is lower in energy than
where they would have been
before.
And so the crystal field
stabilization energy is a way of
indicating whether you have
overall stabilized the system or
not by this splitting.
The way that you would
represent this is you would just
look at where the electrons are
and how much they are
stabilized, again,
three orbitals down minus
two-fifths,
two orbitals up plus
three-fifths.
In this case,
there are three electrons that
are stabilized by minus
two-fifths of the octahedral
crystal field splitting energy,
or you would have a
stabilization of minus
six-fifths times the octahedral
crystal field splitting energy.
That would be the answer to
that part.
Okay.
Let's look at another example.
I will write this in between
here.
Here we have manganese with six
water ligands in brackets and Cl
three on the outside.
What is the
charge of just this coordination
complex?
It has six ligands to this
inside the brackets?
What is the charge of just that
coordination complex overall?
It would be plus three.
And you know that because these
are three negatively charged
counter ions.
When the whole thing is neutral
with three Cl's,
it means that had to have been
plus three.
What is the charge of water?
Zero.
What has to be the charge on
the metal?
Plus three.
Now we can figure out the
d-electron count.
What group are we in?
Seven minus three is four.
We are a d four system.
All right.
Now we have four electrons to
put in, and we are going to have
a choice.
We are going to have a choice
as to whether we put the fourth
electron up here or keep the
fourth electron down here and
pair.
And so both of those are
possibilities.
And it depends on the strength
of the crystal field.
Let's look at those diagrams.
There are two possibilities.
And we have,
again, d x squared minus y
squared   and d z
squared   up here,
we have our t two g system,
our e g.
That is one drawing.
Or, we might have a case where
we have something more like this
where there is a much larger
separation between the sets of
orbitals.
Between the e g and
the t two g.
And so here is our crystal
field.
It is small here.
And here is another crystal
field splitting energy,
and this one is large.
You have a choice.
We have to put in four
electrons.
And depending on whether it is
a small splitting or a large
splitting, you are going to put
them in differently.
In this case,
we have a crystal field
splitting energy that is less
than what we call the pairing
energy.
The pairing energy is how much
energy it takes to pair up the
electrons.
They prefer to have their own
orbital.
They would prefer not to be
paired.
It takes a certain amount of
energy to pair them.
In this case,
because the splitting is small,
this set of orbitals up here
are really not that much higher
in energy than these were.
It is not that hard to put one
up here.
And it takes more energy,
in this case,
to pair them up,
than it does to put one in the
higher level.
This one would have a drawing
like this.
You have four electrons you put
in.
One of them goes over there.
In this case,
we have a really big
difference.
It would take a lot of energy
to put an electron way up here.
In this case,
the splitting energy is greater
than the pairing energy.
This is really a lot higher up.
Here it is small.
It makes not much difference.
Here the energy is large.
In this case,
you would want to put your four
electrons all down in the lower
level.
Let's just take a look at some
of those rules and say them
again.
Here, when the splitting is
small, this is called a weak
field.
The ligands here will be weak
field ligands.
And there will be strong field
ligands.
And we are going to talk about
that next Monday,
how you will learn certain
ligands, and whether they are
weak field or strong field.
If they are weak,
oh boy, they cannot really
split that energy very far.
They do not have a lot of
strength.
They cannot do a huge
splitting.
They just do a little tiny
amount of splitting.
They are pretty weak ligands.
And, in this case,
you would have a strong field,
where you would have a large
splitting.
Those ligands come in.
And, boy, they take those
d-orbital energy levels,
and they split them really far
apart.
Those are strong field ligands.
They create a strong field.
And this is large.
All right.
If we look at some of these
rules then, if our pairing
energy is greater than that
energy difference,
that means you have a weak
field.
It is not much different.
It is a weak field,
not much splitting.
The splitting is small.
And then what you are going to
want to do is put all your
electrons in singly to the
fullest extent possible.
You use both t two g
and e g.
You put them all singly until
you are done,
before you pair.
On the other hand,
if you have a strong field,
that is going to have a really
large splitting.
Big energy difference between t
two g and e g
sets of orbitals.
Then that splitting energy is
going to be greater than the
pairing energy.
It is more favorable to pair
than to make that big jump up to
this higher energy level up
here.
In that case,
what you want to do is you want
to pair them all up in t two g.
And only after this is
completely full and you cannot
put any more electrons in there
do you want to put an electron
way up there in the e g
sets of orbitals.
What this means,
then, is in this case you are
going to have the maximum amount
of unpaired electrons,
because you are going to try to
keep them unpaired for as long
as you possibly can.
And so this is referred to as a
high spin system.
In this case,
you are going to have the
minimum number of unpaired.
You are trying to pair them up
down here before you put one up
here.
This is a low spin system,
minimum number of unpaired
electrons that are possible.
These are our two diagrams that
you will see.
And one question on the problem
set has you drawing these
diagrams for these different
conditions.
Now, this particular one that
we are talking about,
this particular complex is high
spin.
And so next week we are going
to talk about what that is true.
And you will learn about some
of the ligands and be able to
predict whether it is going to
be a high spin or a low spin
system.
We can also go through now and
do electron configurations,
and also the crystal field
splitting energy.
In this case,
our d n configuration
is going to be equal to --
There are three electrons in t
two g and there is one
electron in e g.
And over here,
we have d n equals,
in t two g,
we have four electrons.
Those are the differences in
electron configuration,
and in the crystal field
stabilization energy,
we calculate that.
We have three electrons down
here.
We have three electrons in
minus two-fifths times the
crystal field splitting energy.
And we have one electron up
above, so that is plus
three-fifths there.
And so minus six plus three is
going to give us minus
three-fifths times the
octahedral crystal field
splitting energy for this system
here.
And you do need to put the
symbol for the octahedral
crystal field splitting energy
in this.
Not just the number.
On the other side,
we only have electrons down
here.
And so we are going to have
four that are times minus
two-fifths.
And so our answer is going to
be minus eight-fifths times the
octahedral crystal field
splitting energy.
And every once in a while,
some people like to indicate
that there is also something
paired.
Sometimes you will see this
plus PE, which indicates one
paired electron.
Sometimes you might be asked
for that, so just to be aware.
I think your book doesn't use
this, but you will see that some
places.
That is how we would do those
two.
All right.
Let's quickly look at one more
example.
Here, it would be excellent to
have another board,
but let's quickly do a little
bit of erasing and leave our
framework here.
All right.
Get rid of this over here and
over here.
Okay.
In this case,
we are looking at cobalt plus
two.
The first step is to find the
oxidation number,
but conveniently that was given
to you.
It is plus two.
And then we need to do the
d-electron count.
Group number for cobalt is
nine.
We have 9 minus 2 or 7,
so we have a d seven system.
For this, we will have a
difference, depending on whether
you have a weak field or a
strong field,
on how you put in your seven
different electrons.
Again, if we look at the two
different conditions --
If we first do this with a weak
field, then we are going to want
to put in our electrons to the
fullest extend possible before
pairing.
We would go in and put one,
two, three, four,
five.
Now we put one in all of them.
Then we are going to come back
and do six, seven down here.
And so this will be the maximum
number of unpaired that you can
possibly have for a high spin
system.
In this case,
with a strong field,
it takes a lot of energy to put
the electrons up there.
You are going to want to put
them all in the bottom until you
are done.
And you cannot put anymore down
here when you have this strong
field, when you have this big
large splitting in energy.
The splitting in energy is much
greater than the pairing energy.
Better to pair then to put
electrons up here.
Now we would do one,
two, three, four,
five, six.
And, unfortunately,
we have seven.
One will have to go up there,
but only one.
You see that the diagrams are
different with a d seven
system, depending on whether you
are a weak field or a strong
field.
Here you would have the minimum
number, one, of unpaired
electrons, low spin.
Here you have the maximum
number, which is three.
And we can do our d n
count here.
Now we have five electrons in t
two g and we have two
electrons in e g.
Over here, in t two g,
we have six.
And in e g we have
only one.
And for the crystal field
splitting energy,
on this side we would have 5
times minus two-fifths plus 2
times 3/5, or a total of minus
4/5 times the splitting energy.
Again, we could add two PE for
the pairing energy,
if that was asked for,
so optional plus 2 PE.
And on this side we are going
to have six times minus
two-fifths plus,
we have one three-fifths,
or an answer of nine-fifths
times the octahedral crystal
field splitting energy.
And, again, optional,
we could add three pairing
energies for those.
Okay.
Well, we finished on time given
all the technical issues.
That's great.
You should be able to finish
your whole problem set and have
experience doing these kinds of
diagrams.